what's going on guys it's June we're
about halfway through the year so far a
lot of good movies have come out so far
we know there's a lot of Oscar baits
still ahead but we decided to compile
some of our favorite movies of the year
to date and we've assembled an esteemed
panel of critics to talk about that very
subject first she's a film reporter from
the LA Times and she's a great friend of
the family welcome back Jen Yamato you
seen this guy around here many times you
know from movie review talked with Scott
mance on Collider and he's also you know
this woman from screen junkies news she
does it all around here welcome to the
couch
Ross Cornett oh very glad to be on the
couch so Jen do you want to get us
started with one of the movies that you
really liked so far this year yes I was
so happy when Coralie Farr gets revenge
came along
it's a French language genre movie
released by neon earlier this year what
it is is a revenge movie called revenge
a young woman who goes to a remote
hideaway with her married boyfriend for
a lovely romantic weekend only to have
that totally totally ruined and then
they leave her for dead that's where I
believe that story really begins it's
about her journey it's about her
transformation and it is a really
powerful visceral thriller that base
premise it's sort of like I Spit on Your
Grave meets in the company of men Wow
it's like what you wish would happen to
the men in the company of men it's mixed
language there is some English in it
she's meant to be an American but it's
stylistic in a way that I think elevates
the film some of the aspects of it
aren't necessarily realistic in terms of
how the human body would react to
certain trauma even though it's such
dark subject matter it sounds like a
really accessible right now
suspensful it keeps you on the edge of
your seat Scott manse listen just
because I cannot wait to talk about this
movie it is my favorite movie of the
first half of the year by far it is also
a thriller it is also suspenseful it was
also a very commercially successful film
I loved a quiet place I felt like this
was so unique and different and fresh
and fun and John Krasinski it's his
third movie as a director who knew that
he could do something so confidently and
it's such a bold film because of the
premise and I feel like it is this
year's get out this is an Oscar
contender for best picture for best role
for Best Original Screenplay and I
didn't eleven political commentary in a
quiet place that I might have seen it
get out but I have to give it to you it
is masterfully directed and edited I
thought it was moving it has a lot of
heart more hearts than you'd expect from
a it was great come on I don't think
it's this year's get out yeah doesn't
have to be I think it's this year's best
Cloverfield movie that wasn't cool
[Applause]
we can all agree except for manse not
this year's get out tell me one of your
famous of the year so far yes and it's
one that I've been surprised to see is
as divisive as it is which is hereditary
I really thought that everyone was going
to love this movie not the case
unfortunately however I did this is
director arias tears feature debut it's
such an intense family drama and really
it's more that than a horror movie and
the horror elements are sort of subtly
laid in until it very much escalates and
it's like oh that escalated quickly
yeah and becomes a full-blown Rosemary's
Baby experience by the end of the movie
The Exorcist exactly yeah so it's
playing with very modern ways to tell a
horror story and very classic
it's a metaphor for how we all inherit
patterns in our family we inherit fears
in our family and we inherit curses in
that way and Toni Collette Dodson Oscar
performance yeah for the ferocity for
the total willingness to go to any games
and the reserves and the versatility
that she shows throughout that entire
movie yeah it's emotionally all over the
place don't you ever raise your voice at
me I am your mother
Jen would you drop another one on us
please yes here's the big one already oh
do it it is the best romantic comedy to
come along in years
the original Netflix major motion
picture set it up this is the best
rom-com I've seen in so long
in a genre that has been so dead for so
many years yes yeah that there is a real
it's so funny it stars Zooey Deutsch and
Glenn Powell as two assistants who are
overworked by they're demanding bosses
who work in the same building they meet
cute and then decide to plot to Parent
Trap their bosses together said they can
have some time off
it's brilliant well their bosses fall in
love well they fall
the dialogue is some of the I think the
most astute in acutely real dialogue
that I've seen in not just a romantic
comedy but in most movies yes it just
feels like how real people talk how real
young adult professionals talk another
movie that I think was underserved this
year and I think is a really great
rom-com and also the John Hughes movie
that we deserve is love Simon
necessarily on my list right now but I
just want to take this like tack on to
that it's very much things you've seen
before in John Hughes movies but it's a
story of a boy coming out for the first
time in high school and meeting and
falling in love for the first time it's
gorgeous two movies that I haven't seen
yet two movies that I really want to see
right now thank you ladies uh Scott
mance you have something for us I have
the talk about a romantic comedy yeah I
mean you know like love Simon wonderful
film I love that movie set it up it's on
Netflix now I mean it's a it's a
wonderful film what says a romantic
comedy more than black panther seriously
black panther was fresh it was different
it was a culture Wakanda we never saw
anything like this before any superhero
movie of any kind
Ryan Cooper did a great job directing
that film chadwick boseman was great as
black panther but i got to tell you in a
lot of ways his co-stars were we're even
better than than chadwick boseman uh not
me yes - but I thought it was great but
like all this cast members were
fantastic and it just was a really smart
story it was fresh and for them to be
this far long into the MCU and to really
do something that's different in a genre
that has every reason to be stale and
formulaic black panther is anything but
i thought black panther was fantastic
and it's definitely one of the top ten
best superhero movies of all their best
MCU movie of the year
best MC last year so far okay any more
I watched them both I think that they're
very different movies and infinity words
almost like unlike any other movie
if you're not invested in those 18
previous films it's a very difficult
movie to follow but for me Black Panther
like I know there's like sort of always
a backlash when people really love a
movie and then we find the reasons not
to you I continue to love that movie I
think it's a really great comic book if
I hear any more backlash about
la-la-land Roth why don't you tell us
about another film that you love so far
from this year absolutely well Jenn if
you are tired of formula and if you are
tired of being able to predict what's in
a movie I know you love this one too
sorry to bother you is the antidote for
all of that this comes from boots Riley
it's not out yet it's gonna be out in
July highly recommend that you see this
movie caveat there is truly unlike any
other movie you will see this year it
defies categorization it is surrealist
it is absurdist it totally is it is
being John Malkovich meets do the right
thing bonkers bananas insane and awesome
it has so much social commentary so much
to dig into and talk about after this
movie this will leave you talking for
days it is set in and was filmed in
Oakland California where the trailer the
director is from boots Riley is already
quite known from music as a rapper and
an activist he was very active in the
Occupy movement okay and a lot of
Boots's core themes that have been
prevalent in his work are in this movie
such as how capitalist system sort of
prepare us to give our own power away
among other things it's about
gentrification it's about race in
America today on top of a really fun
original crazy entertaining plot
background Jen Jen please favour us with
another one of your choices there is yet
another genre movie it is called upgrade
upgrade is a sci-fi thriller about a man
who in a terrible mugging gone horribly
wrong loses his wife and is rendered
paraplegic
he then agrees to have an experimental
very high like secret operation done
that fuses an experimental operating
system into his three six million
dollars that allows him the use of his
limbs and thus allows him to seek
revenge against those who do I right and
it's just really fun you feel the DNA of
a lot of like iconic sci-fi genre movies
in this movie like man-machine fused
together what could go wrong is in this
and there's some really inventive very
physical action scenes where the star at
Logan Marshall cream who's so great in
this movie is playing a man who is not
in control of his own body and is
bewildered in his face while his body is
doing all sorts of crazy stuff and
overall I find it a really great
small-scale sci-fi genre movie let's go
to Scott mance and hear about a movie
you know what one of my favorite things
to do every year in fact my favorite
thing to do is Sundance I've gone 16
straight years and the discovery of
seeing a film at Sundance you have no
idea what you're in for
like hereditary you just don't know
because there's no previews there's no
trailers it's all about the discovery
well I knew who mr. Rogers was but I did
not expect to be so moved by won't you
be my neighbor
directed by Morgan Neville I did
recently a bunch of Q&A is with him at
some of the theaters around la that in
the middle of the afternoon on a
Saturday in the summer were sold out and
I started off by saying ladies gentlemen
raise your hand if you never saw mr.
Rogers neighborhood have the people in
the audience never saw it Wow but they
know who mr. Rogers is they know what he
stood for they know what his ideas are
and that's what this movie is it's about
his ideas yeah he's talking to kids but
his delivery is
so comforting for grownups he was
talking to the kids in the room and the
grown-ups sitting behind the kids
watching the show with him I would like
to know what mr. Rogers advice would be
for living in the world of social media
a lot of times even when I when we agree
with someone politically there's no
allowance for the evolution of a human
being anymore certainly in social media
everything is binary you're a good
person or a bad person you're not a
person that's allowed to evolve change
your point of view anything mr. Rogers
allowed for all of humanity
he allowed for his own humanity and by
the end of the movie he allowed he left
for his doubts there's letters revealed
of his doubts that when he knows what
he's doing is he doing anything good it
allowed for that moment of self-doubt at
the end did anything he do impact us
yeah and it just like reveals who we
could be if we were willing to be
vulnerable Ross would you please tell us
about one more movie that you really got
a kick out of this year I thought about
adding first reformed which may end up
on my list of the year yeah it's great I
thought about adding a fun movie like
game night which was surprisingly funny
but maybe not thoroughbreds
have a nice day so many wonderful movies
this year but instead I chose what's
probably the most controversial of the
ones that I love and it's how to talk to
girls at parties is a movie that is a
rotten on Rotten Tomatoes critics did
not like it it is certainly not for
everyone this comes from John Cameron
Mitchell who originated Hedwig yeah yes
star of the feature film Hedwig in the
angry rabbit hole and Robin wall which
is how Nicole Kidman came to be in this
very weird movie basically about punks
and aliens colliding in London oh if
you're not sold sold
then then get out now because it's only
gonna get weirder from there this movie
a lot of ways kind of represents
adolescents even the aliens are going
into different forms they're trying to
understand what they are on earth or in
their other forms they're trying to
understand what their purposes do we
consume our youth
or we consumed by it all of this is very
very messy and you will leave this
either loving it wholeheartedly for it's
on a Bosch speaking weirdness or
absolutely hating it and what is more
punk rock than that Jen let's come back
around to you I know you had one more it
premiered this earlier this year at
Sundance it's called blind spotting
similarly to Roth's in passions pick is
in its own way about sort of existential
inward probing into who we are our debt
our identities who we are in relation to
the world that we have been born into
it's also about privilege and it is also
like sorry to bother you set in and shot
in Oakland California also from Oakland
homegrown filmmakers Raphael Cassell and
daveed Diggs who wrote produced and
start in this film one of the it's about
two guys best friends
one is black one is white one of them
has newly gotten out of jail and is on
parole and it is in his final days of
parole until he is truly free again and
it's about them sort of going out into
this world their daily lives it's also
about how gentrification has changed
their world it's about how black and
white identities are in relation to each
other in close proximity in cities like
this and it's just a really great drama
with a lot of I think funny moments as
well with two great performances you
have to support that so you don't just
get the same old formulae yes garbage
that we get a lot although there have
been a lot of really great movies so far
in the first half 2018 for sure and I
think you had one more floor that I
loved and I was saving this well I was
saving a quiet place for last they just
couldn't continue helping I couldn't
help but you stay quiet about a quiet
place but now the movie won't you be my
neighbor in a quiet place
the movie act you want to end with yes
is annihilation annihilation this movie
worked for me on so many levels cerebral
and it's got a great cast an all-female
cast of a science team that goes into a
mysterious area that might be evolving
due to the presence of alien
intelligence and it is very existential
it has shades of Stanley Kubrick it has
shades of 2001 a Space Odyssey which is
very fitting because this year does mark
the 50th anniversary of 2001 a Space
Odyssey came out on which state which
came out on April 3rd 1969 how to
monitor my Scott manses weird super
berry states yeah but guys I mean this
movie was I've seen it twice now yeah
and it's the kind of film where you will
get more out of it the more that you see
it and the more times you see the film I
just the second time I like that a whole
lot more than I did the first time I
think it is it is an instant sci-fi
classic Scott another great choice you
guys you've listed a lot of movies I
love you've listened movies that have
rocketed to the top of my must-see list
any other honorable mentions or shout
outs you want to make I mean I'll start
with I'll throw one out there that I
haven't heard I was just delighted by
The Incredibles 2 um any others any
others that you were thinking about huh
almost made my list oh oh oh oh you know
why yes this movie because you talked
about someone's opening in July that
we've already seen three identical
strangers this movie is amazing just
seeing this film the less you know about
it the better okay trust me
Ronny oh there's rapid-fire shout outs
Paddington do don't you sleep loveless
is amazing RBG have it yes so many
movies if you haven't seen all of these
movies go watch them all right now
and a lot of them are available on
on-demand and they can watch instantly
so do it I want to thank this esteemed
panel of movie Minds Roth Cornett Scott
manse Jenny Amato thank you so much for
dropping knowledge with just such
thought and care I mean some of your
descriptions are these movies I'm like
wow why haven't I seen that already I
cannot wait
thank you and thank you for watching
screen junkies I'm Hal rod Nick hit us
up on Twitter by like
[Music]